number and that number is two one nine
two david p this is something that's a
bit touchy and i do get a lot of
questions about this it's sort of about
like real life hate mail let me just
play it and then we'll talk about it oh
hi David
my name is Debra and I'm calling from
Newfoundland the planet Labrador Canada
yes I just listened to your piece about
the your latest hatred now and I
wondered if you'd received any kind of
hatred mail that was criminal right and
or yet act on it in the meantime I just
wanted to say thank you for all the
great work we're doing I think I'm going
to use that coupon code I think it's a
treat for tea yes indeed and get myself
a second one we will keep the hatred
crying David thanks so much and take
care bye-bye thank you I appreciate it
so listen the question is there ever
hatred mail or hate mail that we get
that we would consider criminal but the
answer is yes we we do receive things
that warrant the involvement of law
enforcement and fortunately we've build
some great relationships with federal
both federal and local law enforcement
and it's I don't publicize those and
there are specific reasons why and I
don't even really think we need to go
into detail but the answer is yes the
stuff that that is where we believe that
it requires the involvement of law
enforcement and it is unfortunately not
on infrequent it's much more frequent
than I would like
sadly we don't put those on the air and
those go directly to law enforcement and
things things sometimes happen as a
result of those those enquiries that
that we do but we keep those off the air
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about so there's this
new there's new battle lines in the
conservative fight in the LGBT space
which is pushing into
sports and trans kids okay this is the
next wave of anti LGBT activism and
we're going to talk about that we will
also talk about presumably the moving
forward of a proposal that would cut
food stamp benefits for millions of
people economically disastrous but
forget about that morally an abomination
and then we will also talk about the
misspellings the misspellings of many of
our most famous and high-profile
tweeters people that tweet and what we
can sort of deduce from that there's
been some research done about misspelled
high profile misspellings on Twitter
which I think you will find interesting
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show two ways to access it become
a member at WWE at medCom or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show I would love to see you on the
bonus show if you will not be partaking
then we will have a brand new program
for you tomorrow